[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le groupe de chamonix pourrait fort bien
s'appeler cette année le grand prix de
descente en vrille des illusions perdues
il va y en avoir quelques une manière
originale de faire le mur d'ailleurs
cette partie du parcours c'est paraît-il
le mur du départ pas très catholique
cette descente
il accuse même aller plus loin que les
autres passons aux choses sérieuses
voici georges du billard un champion
c'est une pub lui qui détient le record
il a fait dix mètres de plus que ses
adversaires
[Musique]
un autre champion plus grand encore son
frère adrien du bia ouf
il est encore 2 et bien non décidément
il n'y aura personne à l'arrivée
rassurons les âmes sensibles il ya plus
de peur que de mal adrien du billard est
seulement un peu de rock
il a tout de même bien à qui va rester
sur ses skis
albert gars qu'on entretient un suspense
tombera tombera pas soyez tranquille
lui au moins il franchira la ligne
d'arrivée en quatrième position
là on retient son souffle
[Musique]
pour ce skieur rien n'est impossible il
porte le numéro un c'est bon signe
on appelle cela faire l'oeuf en termes
techniques
ce skieur c'est guy périllat aisance
décontraction sûreté des gestes
manifestement il ne veut pas tomber il
digère toutes les bosses avec un bel
appétit
[Applaudissements]
et
mais
quelques mètres encore obtient son
souffle
[Applaudissements]
lui aussi il est tombé mais au bon
moment après la ligne d'arrivée c'est
suffisant pour gagner
[Musique]
c'est un tocard de série du type
randonnée à rouler ainsi pendant 97
jours il ne s'est arrêté que pour
prendre du carburant changer de pneus
mais évidemment pour changer également
deux pilotes
neuf pilotes se sont relayés au volant
durant ces 90 7 jours à l'issue
desquelles ils ont parcouru 200 mille
kilomètres cinq fois le tour de la terre
à 80 5 de moyenne
tout cela sans incidence est la première
grande épreuve d'endurance de ce genre
contrôlée par l'acf une telle
performance valait bien les
félicitations du patron ce que
s'empresse de faire monsieur paul berry
il paraît que nous sommes là dans le
temple du rugby à twickenham ce temple
c'est un vulgaire terra bouées ou des
bulldozers serait sans doute plus à
l'aise que des joueurs de rugby maillot
immaculé pour les anglais du moins pour
le moment
mailhot foncé pour les français pour
être sûr de tenir debout et dont nous
les uns les on tient des individualistes
boniface et dupuy partout à la contre
offensive sans avoir besoin de tuteur on
est faible dans les tribus
deuxième mi temps les français
s'effondre
joli cadeau de la défense française aux
attaquants britannique un essai du
deuxième ligne
harding qui va être transformé par
wilcox larié robes drapées ans paraît
pouvoir in town dans les tribunes
réplique du berger à la bergère un essai
français qui va marquer crauste après un
beau coup de pied de recentrage de
rancoule essai transformé par vanier
match nul 5 à 5 7 équitable mais ne
parlez plus aux français du pape du rock
[Applaudissements]
les nouvelles installations qui
s'offrent comme l'un des plus beaux
fleurons de l'aéroport d'orly le premier
d'europe continentale ont reçu la visite
du général de gaulle
[Musique]
le président de la république inaugurait
ainsi quinze jours avant sa mise en
service la nouvelle aérogare kim et orly
à la mesure de l'avenir une des plus
frappantes réalisation française dira le
chef de l'état
début d'une journée attendue et
longuement préparé le premier ministre
français est venu accueillir à orly le
président bourguiba plus que d'une
visite
il s'agissait d'un rendez-vous à
rambouillet dans le calme de la
résidence présidentielle bien gardée des
indiscrets le général de gaulle allait
s'entretenir avec le président tunisien
[Musique]
long tête à tête d'abord plus tard
élargi sortira-t-il de cette rencontre
une esquisse d'une solution au problème
algérien chefs religieux entourée d'un
vaste traditionalistes souvent moderne
d'un état en pleine évolution
- médecins croient du maroc vient de
succomber brusquement à 52 ans son règne
un moment interrompues s'était raffermi
a surtout en 1955 ou des acclamations
unanime l'avait accueilli après un exil
de près de deux ans on peut dire qu'il
incarne à son peuple à un moment
difficile
[Musique]
après avoir négocié l'indépendance de
son pays il voulu assurer l'avenir de la
couronne en désignant pour son
successeur son fils aîné moulay hassan
aujourd'hui roi sous le nom de l'assam 2
on n'oubliera pas qu'il fût other
tragique de la guerre en ami sûr est que
le général de gaulle le plaça son côté
pour présider au défilé de la victoire
[Musique]
colomb béchar une fusée véronique
s'élève dans le ciel
atteindra 150 km mais durant tout son
voyage électrocardiographe et électro
encéphalographie n'ont cessé de
fonctionner un être vivant était à bord
dans son habitacle on l'a retrouvé en
bonne état le recteur car c'était lui ne
semblait pas se ressentir des 10
secondes pendant lesquelles au sommet de
sa trajectoire
son coeur avait cessé de battre
[Musique]
des milliers de moins de 20 ans venue de
belleville comme de la muette rempile
palais des sports à l'occasion du
festival du rock'n'roll pour vibrer à
l'unisson de chanteurs tels que johnny
hallyday qui ne pas 20 ans et non plus
[Applaudissements]
m
j'ai un métier il a pris ses quartiers
assez tardivement
et bim c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
à
et j'ai invité
des quartiers
j'ai le veston pays c'est le podium
francky jardin a aussi ses partisans
passionnés
[Applaudissements]
et on attend
à
non
rougeau presse
la boue
moi je te plaît
laurent cabrol est une passion d'une
religion une frénésie qui n'a pas
toujours sans casse
[Applaudissements]
as-tu est payante et al
las pour les poux mais moi je suis pas
jaloux
en plus d'heureux termine à 3 plus capé
sur nous dans quelques années ces
frénétiques sur un notaire épiciers et
percepteur et excellent père de famille
c'est au musée du costume dans
l'atmosphère de la mode romantique que
nous avons découvert la jolie madame que
présente pour notre été pierre dalm
silhouette souple dont la jupe est
courte sans excès ensembles fluides qui
glisse sans étrangler une taille qui se
devine mais n'est jamais marqué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les manteaux à manches kimono sont
fendues par derrière et s'orne souvent
de boutonnage très personnel
les robes met le buste à l'aise dans des
corsages légèrement blues ans
[Musique]
parfois aussi la robe s'agrémente d'un
corsage draper un bénitier ou repliés en
enveloppes
le mot d'ordre est toujours souplesse et
fluidité
[Musique]
après ces toilettes dans la ligne se
montre toujours prodigue d'invention la
ligne se gonfle pour le cocktail et le
dîner d'une ampleur modéré hauteur des
hanches
on aimera bien entendu ces tissus
aériens dont le charme garde un parfum
très romantique et à travers plus d'un
siècle les personnages d'époque n'y sont
pas tellement insensible surtout quand
des arcs-en-ciel de paillettes s'allume
sous les voiles des robes du soir
car avec elle s'anime les fêtes
merveilleuse d'une élégance qui évoque
les charmes des îles sous-le-vent de
l'asie des mille et une nuits en passant
par lan des raja et pourquoi pas les
fastes du second empire tels qu'on les
voit à travers un songe de parisienne
[Musique]
jolie madame de printemps oui jali
madame de paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]